Your resume is impressive.
Thank you.
But I have some questions.
If you could be one aquatic mammal, what would it be?
What? A dolphin.
What are your greatest weaknesses? Use song lyrics only.
Five years ago from today, where did you see yourself five years from then?
And don't say here.
Five years ago, I think that I would be...
Wow, this is nonsense.
You gotta ask what you really wanna know and I'm all about being direct.
So, let's get to the point.
Are you responsible?
Yes.
Do you bathe in perfume?
Are you gonna microwave fish in the break room?
People do that?
Do you know how a printer works?
I think so.
She's perfect. Hire her. Don't waste any more of her time.
You're hired.
It's like when people don't use marriott.com to book a Marriott hotel.
That's where you get the best rate.
It pays to book direct.
Will you bring a pack of dogs into the workspace?
No.